I literally shower myself in perfume
would you like to see okay I like to get
here
here armpit armpit wrist spread and then
maybe sometimes like the back your
ankles
and that's it
but maybe not
hey GQ it's Sydney Sweeney and these are
my essentials
[Music]
one of my essentials
sugar this is my breakfast this is my
lunch and this is my dinner
I live and Breathe by Sugar everyone who
is close to me knows that I will get
through the day if I have a good candy
in my purse or if someone else hands me
some sugar so I always have some good
backup this is the Holy Grail of sugar
car ride a take five a little breakfast
Kit Kat a good popcorn mix I'll pour my
Sour Patch Kids in my popcorn bowl so
that when I'm eating my popcorn and
watching a movie I'll get a little
surprise
AirHeads for fun and nerds because I
always forget about nerds
I always travel with disposable cameras
or have it on me or have them piled in
my trailer or at parties I think that
they're just such a fun way of capturing
moments and I like giving them to
everybody to capture things that I might
not even be able to see I have a little
picture book yeah like an old school
picture book because I remember growing
up and going through my grandma or my
mom's little photo albums and I love
that and I kind of want to be able to
give that to my kids one day instead of
just scrolling through a phone so I've
been trying to capture more photos and
puts together little photo albums so I
have that for my family
perfume Armani my way I need more I'm
almost out I was never like a huge
perfume girl growing up because my mom
never really introduced me to it and
then as I got older I started using it
and this has become my scent I love it I
love it so much it smells like flowers
and I feel like a princess whenever I
have it on it's my favorite scent but I
literally shower myself in perfume would
you like to see okay I like to go here
hair armpit armpit wrist spread and then
maybe sometimes like the back your
ankles
and that's it
but maybe not
I can't see far away so I have to wear
glasses and I don't wear contacts which
I probably should but I have a fear of
putting things in my eye which I'm
trying to get over so I'm constantly
either wearing my glasses or my eyes are
so strained and red because they're just
constantly not being able to see so this
is a must I didn't start wearing glasses
until I was like 17 or 18 years old and
the moment I put them on I was like this
is what the world looks like look at the
trees there's leaves
so yeah my glasses
they're dirty though
my next essential is what I'm currently
reading right now and it's Molly
Shannon's Memoir I'm like halfway
through so far but I'm really enjoying
it she sent me the book and I'm really
proud of her
and you guys should read it it's really
good I always have a book with me I try
to read a book a week I love reading I
grew up loving reading I think I read
more books and watch TV I tried getting
into like reading on my iPod my eyes I
get tired and I have to have a paper
book I dream of having like a giant
Library one day I'm just trying to
collect books as I go
I mean
my Armani lip power it's the best color
this is like the most natural for my lip
I think this is 103 right yeah 103. it's
the greatest
lip color on the market when I'm doing
just like natural makeup and no lip
liner I'll use this I use it for carpets
too because it's just it's super pretty
and natural which I like to go for
natural the most when it's just me I
have one in my makeup bag and then I
have one that's in my purse that I'm
carrying a day I have a tendency to lose
things
my Lanai lip sleeping mask it's a must I
have one in every bag every vanity every
bathroom vanilla is my favorite I'm
almost out but I put it on when I sleep
but then I also put it on during the day
which I hope that's correct I hope I
don't get in trouble for that
it's pretty good
it's pretty good
[Music]
my next essential is a one one skin eye
patch these are everything for me I
travel with them I wear them before I go
to work before carpets I try to put eye
patches on every morning just to wake
myself up but these have become my
favorite I used to Sting from eye
patches and this one just nourishes me
the most I hear I'll open it I'll show
you it's like this cool jelly material
and it's blue which is my favorite color
if you'll see it's like kind of jelly
see I can't put it on right now because
my makeup's done when I wear them on
airplanes I'll just wear them the whole
flight and then they dry up but my skin
doesn't so that's that is key
the only drink I drink is water
I only drink water the reasoning is
really strange when I was like 12 for
whatever reason I said I'm only gonna
drink water for the rest of my life
and I just kind of stuck with it
I don't know why I think it was like a
challenge I presented to myself and then
I kept going with it and I like it
because I eat a lot of sugar like a lot
of sugar so I think it balances me out I
probably go through a good like four to
six bottles a day that's good right
[Music]
so another essential which I think is
everyone's essential as a good iPhone
charger I have my European adapter
because you never know where I'm gonna
wake up in the morning I always have my
charger but my phone dies which I kind
of like when it dies because then
the world is quiet
thank you for watching and this is how I
get through life
[Music]